sushila gemire owns a store in the heart
of tamil kathmandu's tourist and
business hub she and her family have
remained safe from kovid but the virus
has hit business hard core
kovid has hurt us people are afraid to
come out
the bars and clubs are closed and even
if they were open people wouldn't come
during the second wave last year the
delta variant was killing hundreds of
people
hospitals were running out of oxygen
cylinders and intensive care beds
this time the omicron strain which is
more transmissible is spreading to the
community health experts say it is
infecting nearly every household in the
valley but hospital admissions and
fatalities are significantly lower nepal
experienced a surge in covid cases this
week with more than 10 000 people being
infected every day it's a record daily
high for the country since the start of
the pandemic the government projects
that daily infections may double by the
end of this month and has implemented a
series of measures to curb the surge the
kathmandu district administration office
suspended major services after a number
of its staff contracted covid including
the chief district officer
we are focused on discouraging mass
gatherings in large crowds and instead
encouraging people to follow government
health protocols
schools are shut till the end of the
month and frontline workers are
receiving booster doses gatherings of
more than 20 people are banned and masks
are mandatory outdoors people will need
vaccine cards to enter public spaces and
to access public services the third wave
has infected health workers in hospitals
and health care facilities in large
numbers
the previous wave left our health care
system in shambles we were unable to
cope with the overwhelming number of
patients this time we have to look out
for our health professionals who are the
backbone of the system
only 40
of nepal's 30 million people are fully
vaccinated fifty percent have received a
partial dose
with a relatively low vaccination rate
experts say nepal should expand its
vaccination drive mask up and maintain
social distance ramyata limbu al-jazeera
kathmandu